you're good Bitcoin is finally making
some nice moves uh because this was the
projection from the Sunday update we
were in this Zone in the thirty thousand
five hundred Zone and I was expecting
you know a push-up that's what happened
but I was expecting this push to
continue and be further up make a
deviation okay and then once price gets
back inside the range then this is when
you can enter the short okay that's what
I was expecting both instead you know
Bitcoin pushed a bit into the deviation
and dump okay so at this point yesterday
I wasn't confused I was like what's
going on here
it was that you know the move to the
upset I'm not price is going to go lower
okay but then I remembered that we were
in a Range okay this one here okay this
dotted line that's your mid-range and
that you know if you check what happens
previously this should be a strong
support okay and you can see that in
this Zone
they made some business okay they don't
pressure away to fill this week here let
me Mark it for you the Phillies here
they feel the 50 of the week all right
and then I saw another week here okay so
anyway long because this has to get
filled okay but then that week got
filled by the next by the next candle
what about the next two candles this one
okay so the imbalance now is retraced
now what I want to see here
is Bitcoin getting back here above the
mid-range you know for a new push up and
last night I I was gonna go to sleep
okay this was very late for me I'm my
sleep pattern needs to be broken at the
moment
and when I saw this here in the scandals
I said okay I'm gonna I'm gonna leave uh
a long running overnight
the position size is quite small okay
and and I will cut to this okay I woke
up to this pump they
did a deviation now above the range
highs okay other than have a stake
profits order so you know I haven't
taken profits yet now I'm trying to
think what I'm gonna do that's what I'm
filming this video because it also helps
me to identify the next move because you
know to work hard in analysis to share
with my community
it just makes me you know go through the
analysis uh several times until I'm
confident with it okay so uh this is why
I also do these videos it's also of
course to help you but it also helps me
okay so now we have this deviation okay
um we're gonna discuss if that's enough
or we can expect price to come a bit
higher first okay but let me tell you
something first if you remember from the
previous video
um from the Sunday update on Twitter I
was telling you that all these candles
okay well these are Russia that I'm
marking you okay this this arrows are
marking large green candles or wigs why
because you can see how the market maker
is pushing price off very aggressively
with large green candles or Wicks and
then they retrace price back down
immediately
okay you can see all the time here here
here again it happens here look at that
another large green candle price gets
retraced week price gets retraced okay
if we come here again we'll see the same
thing okay Larson
look what price does okay it retraces
and what do we have now another large
screen candle so what I understand from
this is that the market maker is pushing
price up
just to build shorts okay that's what
I'm telling you that what I expect here
okay let me remove all this mess what
I'm expecting from here is you know a
deviation above range size okay so that
would be
above this one here we've just seen a
deviation now the question is sorry now
the question is if this deviation is
enough or not but what I was expecting
is abbreviation
and I think the price is likely to drop
lower okay I'm right below this range
that's what I think of course uh I might
be wrong with this one and if I'm wrong
with this one uh I'll tell you I'm wrong
with this one but for now you know it's
not invalidated
so this is what I'm believing at the
moment okay you shouldn't arrange when
you see a deviation then you see price
breaking out in the opposite direction
okay
um so let's see what it does here now
what I think to be honest uh well I have
mixed feelings okay
the first thing that I can tell you is
that this pump
you can't trust it okay I'm gonna tell
you why check at what time this pump
happened okay it happened from 5 am
until 8 AM that's the Asian session now
we know what happens usually to Asian
pumps they get retraced
when well they usually get retraced in
the next New York session
or if New York doesn't retrace that pump
then Asia does it themselves in the next
session okay so what I'm telling you
with this is that likely but first we're
gonna go into high block capital okay
we're going to have low Capital we're
going to check if there is any more
liquidity above here or if they fit all
those liquidations that we saw that are
they and that price can go down okay or
have another last push-up before coming
down Okay so let's go through it
okay 12 hours time frame let's start
with this one okay I see that there is
two liquidity zones one is at 31 600
that hasn't been tapped yet okay and
we're actually close to that one and the
other one is to downset 30
325 again
it's possible that both of these
liquidation zones get hit today okay but
which one is closer I would say that
this one is close to 31 600 okay so that
one is more likely to get hit today now
if you're going to the seven days time
frame this is when things are going to
get interesting okay check this out
okay look at that you see that yellow
bar those are liquidations you can see
how price you know set that week hit
those liquidations then Ray Trace but
they didn't really hit all those
liquidations because if you check here
31 600 again
you have the same in the 12 hours time
frame on 31 650.
all right so that liquid to the upside
is not fully taken okay weather is more
liquid if they continue to push price up
another you know two three hundred
dollars that's why it's possible that we
see today one last stop hunt headless
liquidations around Thirty One Thousand
seven hundred and then that's when you
know if we drop back into the range
that's when you can be more confident
about opening short positions okay but
because there is some liquidity still up
there
it's likely the price you know makes
another visit to this Zone not one month
time frame
let's check this you can say here even
more clear okay the liquidation is at 31
600 but look at this 31 700 they didn't
hit this ones why
that's the question that you have to ask
yourself all the time in the markets
okay now my answer
might be right might be wrong but the
way that I understand this is that the
market maker hit these liquidations at
31 600 then don't price quickly
so the retail Trader can open shorts
okay and those sorts you know High
leverage Source they're gonna have their
liquidations at 31 700 okay and this is
going to result in adding more liquidity
into this Zone 31 700 so then if they
make a new push higher towards this Zone
they can hit even more liquidations than
before
okay so kind of building Liquidations in
that zone that's what I can understand
okay that's another The Narrative that I
believe so let's go back to the
charitable we can dismiss the idea of
Bitcoin you know revisiting 31 700 still
now hang on before we go into the chart
liquidation levels let's check this out
okay
Come on load
were excited okay a little bit okay the
Delta is not telling me much you can see
that's pretty much been to zero or Andre
and reset now there is three billions
worth of liquidations at the moment of
long liquidations not much to be honest
so I'm gonna ignore the Delta for now
but what I want to check are those
expect other right of this chart okay
these are the high liquidation Zone all
right here you can see
if we check this one around thirty
thousand
900 I would say
that's the area the very Squad of
liquidity okay Thirty thirty thousand
nine hundred also to the downside here
you have also here 30 280 another Zone
with high liquidity but if you take to
the upside about 32k
there is not really much liquidity at
the moment look at this spikes you know
that is smaller than this ones okay
so that when when the liquidation levels
are like this then I'm naturally
favoring lower prices okay
again we could see one last stop hunt to
31 700 boo I'm Not Really Gonna favor
lower prices from here
you understand now let's go back to
bitcoin we're back in the charts I want
to keep this video nice and short so I
can edit it quickly and upload it to
YouTube quickly because my internet
information is not as great here okay
but
be very careful wise because we've been
in this range for quite some time okay
since the 21st of June so just be
mindful because you know when we're
arranged there is a lot of liquidity in
this one here and in this one here now
what you have to try to understand is
what price is gonna go next okay that's
a difficult part about this game you
know it's easy to put a limit order and
take profits order and close the chart
and stop loss okay but
what is difficult is to understand the
direction of the move okay and I can
tell you that you know I always have in
Twitter
bulls and birds complaining because they
don't believe in my projection so when
we were in this Zone
I was favoring you know a push higher
okay and then a drop lower when I when I
uh said when I posted this projection
the Bears didn't believe that price
could pump you know seven hundred
dollars
why why wouldn't you believe that price
can put 700 okay and then I had here
people saying that this high was not
going to break look at this is broken
okay
so now you're gonna tell me that
it's not possible the price goes to 29
500 again what do you say with time okay
we'll see with time again I might be
wrong but when you say that it's
impossible
then you are immediately wrong because
nothing is impossible in trading okay
so pretty much guys be careful here I'm
gonna tell you what I think we got this
sweep of the heist now this might not be
enough we might see another push a bit
higher towards this one here
31 700 we'll see okay but yes this is a
deviation about the previous size is
what we were talking about also this
Asian pump here
I don't like it Asian pumps get for the
retrace in the next New York New York
session
or in the next Asian session okay so
that means that in 24 hours
this Asian pump should get fully redress
okay
like this
okay to again to thirty thousand five
hundred that's what I believe uh let's
see how that plays out soon we're gonna
get out of this range I don't know if
it's gonna go I don't know if it's going
to be to the upside or the alarm side I
have a feeling
that you know they are sitting at
deviation
above the highs just to drop lower okay
but time will tell
the only thing that I can do now is
reacting to price okay that's how
Traders work so that's pretty much what
I think guys be mindful of that Asian
pump
I'll tell you again I don't like it and
always you can search in Twitter crypto
Evolution pump or in YouTube and you're
gonna see that they usually uh retrace
the whole Asian pump okay so be very
mindful guys
uh now before I close the video I want
to show you something
and why I couldn't upload a video in the
last two days okay
now the reason that I've been missing
the last couple of days is because on
Monday I released more places for my
educational trading course this is my
website you can go here through the
questions to get some more info
um okay and then if you click in courses
here these are the courses that I made
available August I met two groups they
are fully booked now September two
groups and October two groups these four
are harmful so if you come here you see
that 22 are in a stock each group has 40
places
so if you are interested and you've been
waiting for this be quick because
probably by the end of this week or next
week there might be all of them full
okay so go through the website also if
you book for October you get a discount
for anticipation okay
um yeah I've done already
uh the course of February that was uh 30
people for free that I gave for a
giveaway then I did March April May and
June okay so in total that's you know
around
more than 250 people I think around 300
people
um so far the feedback is very good
people are learning so you know I invite
you if you are interested to go through
the website get some information and
book the course if you want okay so
that's pretty much everything guys
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you tomorrow